Everything you're saying is a lot about
righteousness by faith. Um
And I know you study a lot of Ellen
White, so when she says that if they had
followed the 1888 message, we would have
already been gone to heaven.
Can you talk about that? I I think
that's really important how
if that's the case,
why don't we study more of what they
said and have you studied that much? I
don't hear you talking about that much
cuz I listen to you a lot. I'd like to
hear more about that.
No one can say why the church does not.
Well, we can't say the church does not
because we don't know what the entire
church body does around the world. Ellen
White on two occasions said that Christ
would have come back
after 1888 and shortly after uh sometime
in the early '50s, she made a similar
statement. Now, when the Israelites went
into the wilderness, it was not God's
will they spent 40 years.
He wanted to take them directly to
Canaan land. Unbelief allowed him to
cause him to curse them. It was a curse
and sent them back into the wilderness
40 years. The same with us, unbelief.
Yes, Ellen White said that.
And it's it's tragic that the church did
not respond as the church should have
responded to the message of
righteousness by faith. It didn't and
here we are today.
There's nothing to prevent us from
studying
as individuals
what was taught. You see, as individuals
You see, we're not saved as a church.
We're
Mind, Character, and Personality, volume
2, page 423, paragraph 2. The gospel
deals with individuals.
I run across a lot of people. The church
has no outreach program. The church I
said, "Well, you do one."
I mean, do you need your family to tell
you how to get along with your friend or
how to arrange an ultimate friend? Why
do you need the church? The church
doesn't help you sin. Why does the
church need to help you to do something
that's right? You know, you figure out
something that you can do for God
without the church. One day the church
structure will no longer exist as it is.
What will we do? Don't wait for the
church. I can't answer why the church
does not, nor can I say the church does
not because I don't know what the entire
church does north, south, east, and
west. Now, it may not appear to be a
popular subject. Yes, but we must take
individual decisions, make individual
decisions to study that which tends to
bring us to Christ and that which may
hasten the second coming of Jesus
Christ. We must make personal decisions
to do that. Yes, my brother.
I think rephrasing Is it sound?
Rephrasing it would be
when the rubber hits the road,
how do you overcome sin? Okay. All
right. Let's get to that.
the 1888 message, what you basically
preach, but
I don't know why you don't bring Jones
and Waggoner into it. Like You don't
know what? I don't know why you don't
bring Jones Jones and Waggoner's name
into it because if you study what
they've
taught, you've got basically She said
they said it better than she could have.
So, I think that
everyone's arguing about Oh, they
apostasize all this
Leave that alone. That's throwing the
baby out with the bathwater. We need to
understand what they said so that we can
be
become like Christ. Okay. All right. All
right. That's what I'm talking about.
Now, when I preach about tithe, I don't
mention J. N. Andrews.
But he was the one who worked out the
tithing for the church.
When I preach about the state of the
dead, I don't mention O. R. L. Was it
Crozier who worked it out? I don't. So,
if I talk about righteousness by faith,
I don't have to mention J. N. Andrews. I
The only one I really mention frequently
is Ellen White. But I can accept what
they've said without mentioning a name
or giving credit to them. Credit goes to
God.
Again, the question is how do you
overcome sin? By the righteousness of
Christ because the sinless life of
Christ is the power that enables us and
that power is mediated through the word
of God. You know, when the sinner
brought Let me pray again. Father,
please be with me and all of us
listening. Let truth triumph, I pray in
Jesus' name. Amen.
You read Leviticus chapter 1. Let's go
to Leviticus 1. Let's read from verse 1.
Quickly, quickly, quickly. Who has it?
Who has it?
Where is Joshua?
My friend, my little friend who was
sitting right here.
Oh. Hi, Josh.
I just missed you from right here.
That's all. God bless you. Okay.
All right.
Joshua is my boy. Okay.
Do we have Leviticus 1?
Who has Leviticus 1? All right. Someone
read verse King James version. And the
Lord called unto Moses and spake unto
him You can come to the mic if you like
and read.
Out of the tabernacle of the
congregation saying what?
Speak unto the children of Israel and
say unto them, "If any man of you bring
an offering unto the Lord, you shall
bring your offering of the cattle, even
of the herd and of the flock."
Pause. You've got to bring an offering.
Don't go. Stay there.
You got You got to bring an offering.
That's important. You have to bring an
offering. Now, if his offering be a
Verse 3.
If his offering be a burnt sacrifice of
the herd, let him offer a male without
blemish.
Pause. Let him offer a male
without blemish.
A male without blemish. Now, how will he
know the animal is without blemish?
Come on. How will he know the animal is
without blemish?
He looks at it.
He examines it.
Now,
verse 4.
And he shall put his hand upon the head
of the burnt offering.
Where does that happen?
In the outer court. Yes. Who is there
with the person who brings the lamb?
The priest. What does the priest also
have to do?
He has to examine.
Now, listen to me carefully as we talk
about how do you conquer sin.
Two living beings enter the outer court,
the sinner
and the lamb.
Are you following me?
Which one does the priest examine?
The lamb.
I'm talking to myself again.
Which one does the priest examine? The
lamb Not the guy.
Your salvation is based on how good you
are.
It is based
on Jesus, but you have to
bring him. Now, "For God so loved the
world that he gave" What do you call
that?
A gift.
Well, yeah, okay, but I want the word
gift. You're right, but I want gift.
Christ is a gift to the world. Are you
following me? Not to be given back to
God.
So, you bring the gift. This is Christ.
The priest accepts Christ.
At the higher level.
When you bring Christ to God,
God accepts Christ and consequently
accepts you. Why? Because you've brought
Christ. You don't hand Christ to God.
It's not a long-distance transaction.
You have given your life to Christ.
That's essential.
You bring to the Father the life of
Christ, the righteousness of Christ,
which is sufficient for the Father. The
Ellen White said, "It's not important
what God thinks of you.
It's important what he thinks of Jesus."
But you've got to bring Jesus
and hold onto him so that you are
accepted in
the beloved.
Are you listening to me?
You bring Jesus.
And the man or the woman who brings
Jesus can never be rejected by the
Father. If you give yourself to him
and accept him as your savior, then
sinful though your life may have been,
for his sake,
for his sake, you're counted righteous.
Christ's character stands in place of
your character and you are accepted by
God just as if you had never sinned.
Steps to Christ, page 62, paragraph 2.
You bring Christ, but when you bring
Christ, you're saying, "I accept the
righteous life of Christ. I accept
Christ's life of submission to the
Father. I accept Christ's life of
unselfish service. I accept all of that
as mine."
You don't hand Christ to God and say,
"Here you go."
By bringing Christ, you accept, you
believe that Christ can do for you. His
righteousness is sufficient for you
because it is not your righteousness.
Because the righteousness that qualifies
you for place in God's kingdom is
sinlessness.
The life of Christ had no sin. That
animal had no blemish. The sinner had to
bring the animal and the animal was
accepted. Bring Christ to God. How do
you do that? By surrendering to Christ.
And the person who's in Christ
is accepted by the Father. But by
bringing Christ, you're saying, "I
surrender to Christ. I accept his
righteous life as everything the Father
desires." And if that's genuine, that
righteous life in Christ works itself
through you. That's the way it was for
Christ when he was on the earth. John
14:10, "Believest thou not that I'm in
the Father and the Father in me? The
words that I speak unto you, I speak not
of myself, but the Father that dwelleth
in me."
He doeth the works.
When you accept Christ, it's Christ in
you and you in Christ. As long as that
union exists,
you're safe.
And if it is genuine, and the only way
it can exist is if it's genuine, the
life of Christ will express itself
through you.
Victory over sin is the righteousness of
Christ as a practical principle in your
life and that power is the word of God.
Are you with me? The word of God.
Because God created by His word. God
speaks righteousness by His word. God
heals by His word. He cast out demons by
His word. Christ Himself is the word to
bring Christ is to bring the word. The
word of righteousness, the word of life,
the word of victory, the word of
everything.
Bring Christ to God. Don't bring a
church. Don't bring a doctrine. Bring a
person. That person is both man and God.
And you come with Christ to the Father.
You say, "Father, I come in the name of
Jesus."
Holding on to Jesus.
Don't let go.
That power of Christ will transform you.
But as Jesus said in John 15,
"Abide, abide, abide, abide." Keep
holding on. That's the secret. Keep
holding, keep holding, keep holding. And
that keep holding is done by constantly
being in the word of God and in pray.
Keep holding on to Jesus. That which
thou hast, hold fast. We're told
Revelation twice. Hold fast.
Because the devil will try to break that
bond between you and your savior.